FAVORITE SCIENTIFIC EQUATION?
I LOVE THE EQUATION
FOR KINETIC ENERGY
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY ACCESSIBLE
AS, LIKE, A BASEBALL
HITTING YOU IN THE FACE
AT 100 MILES PER HOUR.
YOU CAN DESCRIBE
HOW MUCH ENERGY IT HAS,
AND YOU CAN ALMOST
FEEL THAT.
AND IT'S 1/2 TIMES
MASS VELOCITY SQUARED,
BUT, YOU KNOW, THAT'S GETTING
INTO THE MATH OF IT.
I LIKE BERNOULLI'S EQUATION.
P1 PLUS RHO GH...
I'M NOT GONNA...
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT EQUATION,
WE WOULDN'T BE FLYING FROM THE
WEST COAST TO THE EAST COAST,
OR AROUND THE WORLD.
WELL, MY FAVORITE EQUATION
IS A MATHEMATICAL ONE,
WHICH IS E TO THE POWER
OF I PI PLUS 1 EQUALS 0.
'CAUSE IT CONNECTS THE FIVE
FUNDAMENTAL MATHEMATICAL
CONSTANTS.
IT LOOKS BEAUTIFUL.
IF YOU'RE INTO THAT KIND
OF THING, IT'S BEAUTIFUL,
BECAUSE IT JUST WORKS,
AND IT CONNECTS EVERYTHING,
AND IT'S THERE.
AND IT'S OF NO VALUE
TO THIS SHOW.